le 28 septembre dernier à l'issue du
conseil municipal Maurice venant mère
adjoint socialiste des Mureaux a
présenté sa démission la raison invoquée
les agressions dont il a été victime
depuis deux ans agression raciste et
homophobes que résume cette phrase toi
le blanc quitte la ville on est chez
nous l'affaire a fait grand bruit
exploitée par certains médias ou
certains partis politiques nous avons
décidé afin que chacun puisse juger en
conscience de diffuser d'intégralité de
l'intervention de Boris Venon la voici
je suis arrivé au Mureaux voici des
armées 14 ans j'ai eu un vrai coup de
coeur pour cette ville que j'ai trouvé
être un bel exemple de vivre ensemble
certes ce vivre ensemble ne se déroule
pas toujours dans une harmonie parfaite
mais il me semble que pendant
l'essentiel des années que j'ai pu vivre
ici
la ville connaissait un équilibre une
certaine cohésion sociale c'est pour
cette raison que j'ai décidé de m'y
installer et dit fonder une famille ici
tout le monde au-delà des origines de
chacun se parlent vit ensemble partage
et échange ou plutôt devrais-je dire se
parler vivait ensemble partager ou
échanger
car cette intervention est d'abord celle
d'un citoyen inquiet du délitement du
lien social dans notre ville une ville
qui a changé récemment depuis deux ans
en me référant une expérience
personnelle j'ai subi 11 agressions ou
moi-même ou ma famille nous sommes
sentis menacés jusque dans notre
intégrité physique là où pendant 12 ans
je n'ai jamais connu d'épisode de cette
nature ces derniers épisodes je ne vous
cache pas ont été violents et ont
profondément remis en cause le lien que
j'avais avec la commune et avec ses
habitants je me suis vu reproché d'être
qui je suis
ces épisodes et encore plus le dernier
en date ont été marqués par de la
violence verbale des masses physiques
allant jusqu'à la menace de mort et aux
insultes homophobes et racistes
le Blanc Kit ma vie on est chez nous ici
c'est ce que je me suis entendu dire
avant qu'on me poursuivre jusque devant
mon domicile pour me menacer de mort
ensuite
oui les citoyens d'origine européenne
peuvent faire l'objet de racisme et
c'est un homme dans tout le parcours
politique s'inscrit à gauche qui vous le
dit et j'insiste évidemment sur ce point
que vous savez pourquoi
face à ce type de situation je dois dire
que la réponse des autorités publiques
hors personne présente ici évidemment a
été pour le moins décevante puisque
passer le premier moment d'écoute
attentive j'ai dû à un moment donné
m'expliquer sur ce qui dans mon
comportement aurait été de nature à
provoquer l'agression dont j'ai été la
victime toute chose n'étant pas
également par ailleurs j'ai une pensée
pour les femmes victimes d'agression qui
venaient déposer plein de dans notre
ville
j'ose espérer qu'on en est plus à
demander aux femmes victimes de violence
de quelle façon elle s'habille
il y a encore des efforts à faire en
matière d'accompagnement des victimes
chez nous et je tiens de lire à ce
conseil ou du moins de certaines
catégories de victimes
guilde de préciser que j'attends
toujours des nouvelles d'autorité
judiciaire plus de moins après les faits
ce partage d'une expérience personnelle
que je vous livre pour lesquelles
j'espère vous pardonnerez cette écart
une habituelle de ma part et révélateur
à mon sens d'évolution a plus large
échelle
révélatrice d'un respect d'État droit de
esprit humaniste qui se délite petit à
petit sur notre commune et perdre du
terrain au profit d'une forme de repli
communautaire et d'entre soi que j'ai pu
constater à plusieurs reprises j'ai bien
dit communautaire j'assume ce mot qui
pourrait éventuellement en déranger
certains j'ai adhéré à cette équipe
municipale parce que la pratique
municipale ici aux Mureaux étaient et
toujours de considérer que la ville est
une est indivisible et non une addition
de communauté comme ça peut être
pratiqué ailleurs au sein même de Grand
Paris c'est Noël
j'appelle chacun autour de cette table à
préserver cette tradition qui honore la
ville et que nous devons parce qu'il
faut rendre à César ce qui est à César à
François Garet qui a toujours su
maintenir cette vision républicaine et
universaliste dans cette commune peuplée
de personnes
issues de tous les horizons
les élus qui seraient tentés de dévier
de cette tradition de cette vision
humaniste précipiterait la chute de ce
territoire fragile et serait de mon
point de vue indigne de leur mandat
au-delà de mon expérience d'habitants je
tiens aussi à témoigner comme adjoint au
maire en charge de l'urbanisme de la
nécessité de relever la conscience
citoyenne de nos concitoyens qui ont de
plus en plus tendance à oublier que
l'intérêt général ce n'est pas
l'addition des intérêts particuliers
nous passons désormais l'essentiel de
notre temps à gérer les demandes de
dérogation des habitants et alors
expliquer pourquoi non décidément non la
règle ne pourra pas être adaptée à leur
situation particulière qu'elle existe
pour permettre
de faire en sorte que le confort des uns
ne viennent pas perturber la
tranquillité des autres c'est à dire de
leurs voisins je dis cela est entendu
que je vous parle là des personnes qui
jouent le jeu de la loi et la règle en
prenant en considération les obligations
auxquelles elles sont censées se
soumettre nous constatons toutefois tous
les jours que les habitants qui ne se
soucient plus de la règle commune sont
de plus en plus nombreux si la ville des
Mureaux mais je le tiens à dire fait
dans ce domaine son travail en
manifestant auprès des autorités
judiciaires les infractions je ne peux
que regretter que celle-ci ainsi que
d'une manière générale l'état laisse
faire ne se saisisse pas de ces
désordres du quotidien qui sont ceux qui
a fait 10 le plus le tissu social pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'ils ont
qu'on les a sous les yeux tous les jours
si la ville peut faire beaucoup et fait
beaucoup bien qu'on puisse toujours
faire mieux je considère à titre
personnel que d'autres acteurs publics
ne sont pas à la hauteur de ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire Grand Paris c'est
néo-az qui aurait pu être un bel outil
si on avait fait le choix comme certains
d'entre nous l'avait préconisé d'en
faire une communauté d'agglomération
centrée sur une stratégique plutôt
qu'une grosse communauté urbaine
incapable de gérer les compétences de
proximité qu'on lui a confié comme en
témoigne le service déplorable en
matière d'ordures ménagères de
déchetterie ou de voirie fait la
démonstration tous les jours de ce qu'il
ne faut surtout pas faire
faut dire c'est un jugement personnel
que sa présidente est à l'audace que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est à la modestie
mais sans doute certains usines
partageons pas de point de vue comme
j'ai moi-même pu malheureusement
expérimenter leurs dernières élections
départementales enfin et surtout
devrais-je dire je vais vous dire un mot
de l'État au sens d'institution dont
j'estime qu'il est le principal
responsable de la situation que je vous
ai décrit en propos introductif comment
espérer que notre commune puisse aller
mieux si l'État ne cesse de la
considérer que tout comme d'autres
territoires franciliens comme un canal
naturel à la résolution d'une panne
partie de ces problèmes
que je ne mets pas sur le même plan mais
de sites d'accueil et d'enfants de
djihadiste de retour de Syrie en passant
par les personnes à la rue qu'il faut
mettre à l'abri dans des hôtels du 115
et qui auront vocation à rester ensuite
sur le territoire contribuant ainsi à sa
précarisation quotidienne là où les
villes plus privilégiées de notre
département sont laissés soigneusement à
l'écart
heureusement que le Président de la
République est venu faire son fameux
discours sur le séparatisme chez nous
voici deux ans maintenant sans doute une
illustration du en même temps qui n'est
que le dernier avatar d'une certaine
forme d'hypocrisie politique
voici les points d'alerte républicaines
que je tenais à vous adresser comme
citoyen comme militant politique et
comme élu
aujourd'hui je fais le constat qui
matrice qu'être blanc à thé non
communautaire et gay au Mureaux ça pose
un problème
c'est donc avec une certaine forme de
solennité et aussi un émotions que je
m'adresse à vous ce soir pour participer
à vos côtés une dernière fois à nos
travaux collectifs puisque vous l'aurez
compris ce sera pour la dernière fois
car je m'apprête dans les jours à venir
une fois mes dossiers transmis et notre
réunion monsieur Riou sera
occasion car je m'apprête à rendre mes
fonctions je voulais vous expliquer les
raisons et le sens de cette démarche
dans l'espoir que ce que je vous ai
partagé trouve à la fois une oreille
attentive un esprit bienveillant et une
conscience républicaine
je pars après 14 ans de vie au Mureaux
et 8 ans de mandat j'estime avec le sens
du devoir accompli à mes fonctions
actuelles ou passées je repense avec
satisfaction à l'obtention du Label
Ville Internet par exemple ou bien
encore la refonte du Schéma de Cohérence
urbaine l'an dernier en passant par la
mise en place du permis de loué ou la
définition de projet structurantes
telles que le cœur de ville qui a fait
l'objet de nos travaux ce soir
ces travaux je ne les ai pas accompli
seul et je veux témoigner ici devant les
élus de l'excellence et de l'implication
exemplaire de beaucoup de services
municipaux avec qui j'ai la chance de
travailler ces dernières années que ce
soit la direction de l'urbanisme en
passant par la Délégation Générale ou
par le cabinet du maire passait et
présent en passant par d'illustrez
anciens qui sont aujourd'hui partis ou
très bons agents qui sont encore
aujourd'hui dans les murs l'équipe
municipale en place peut s'estimer
chanceuse vraiment d'être épaulé par des
agents publics efficaces pour la plupart
d'entre eux et qui vont largement
au-delà leur fiche de poste je tiens à
leur dire merci pour ces moments de
partager au service de l'intérêt général
je tiens à témoigner ici aussi de
l'implication de certains de mes
collègues élus ici présents ceux qui
travaillent dans l'ombre et qui font que
la ville tourne je vais vous saluer mes
chers collègues qui ne prenaient pas la
lumière alors que c'est à vous que l'on
trouverait rendre hommage parce que oui
faire avancer concrètement la commune ça
ne se passe pas à la terrasse des cafés
ou à coups de messages sur des boucles
wattsapp ça se passe sur le fond des
dossiers dans des réunions tous ces
moments ingrats sont reconnaissances qui
permettent d'aller de l'avant et font
l'essentiel du travail de l'élu sans
pour autant se voir j'étais ici à saluer
puisqu'ils sont pas là d'ailleurs
Bernardo et Marianne canto qui ne sèche
plus ici mais qui correspondent à mon
sens à la description que je viens de
faire il y en a d'autres autour de la
table je ne laisserai pas par respect
pour leur sens de la modestie je salue
tout de même particulièrement Isabelle
et Luis avec qui j'ai le plaisir de
travailler au sein de notre délégation
thématique particulière
je pense enfin aux habitants dont j'ai
eu le plaisir de croiser la route
sauf trop trop peu nombreux qui pensent
d'abord aux autres avant que de penser à
eux-mêmes et dont on a deux
représentants dans la salle ce soir et
qui peuplent le tissu associatif de
cette ville dont la richesse représente
sans doute la principale lueur d'espoir
pour la santé démocratique et citoyenne
des Mureaux
ce soir je vous remercie de votre écoute
et je vous dis au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]